THE FANTASTIC
JESPER FAST LEADS IT BACK FOR
STAAL.
STAAL HAS IT TAKEN AWAY FROM
HIM, NICE TO
D'ANGELO.WAITING.
GOT IT TO  ANDREI SVECHNIKOV,
HE PUT IT RIGHT IN IT WILL
BE VINCENT TROCHECK'S NINTH OF
THE SEASON, FOR TONY DeANGELO,
HIS 12th POWER PLPLBATTLE WITH
THE SUPPORT OF ANDREI.
>> Mike: BACK TO ACTION HERE
LATE IN THE FIRST PERIOD.
GOOD POF THE
PNC ARENA SHOW CONTINUOUS.
NICE L: IS A FELLOW COACH, HE
NOW IT IS MR. 400, SEBASTIAN IN
HIS 400tDAY,
>> Tripp: THE MAGICAL THINGS
THAT THE HURRICANES CAN S WILL
PUCK AND GET IT TO
DEFLECTED AND IN THE CORNER.
SEBASTIAN AHO GETS TO IT,
LOOKING FOR TEUVO TERAVAINEN. O
HIS TEAMMATE, WE HOPE  WORRY AB
THE FACT THEY ARE AGING ME IN
DOG YEARS.
>> Mike: SPIN
THE CANES GET THEIR THREE GOAL
LEAD BACK, IT IS 4-1, AWAY.
ANDREI SVECHNIKOV,  TO NINO
>> Tripp: THIS WAS A LACROSSE
CALL, WHY DO I SAY THAT? ? RANG
ZONE.
PUCK WORKS FOR YOU.
GOOD WORK THERETHE POINT.
RIGHT ACROSS TO ARTEMI PANARIN,
TRTR
ANDERSEN HAD JUST MADE A HECK
OF A SAVE
THE CANES WILL CLEAR, MAKES OUT
TO CENTER ICE, THOUGH.
>> Tripp: THEY ARE NEVER OUT OF
HE WILL DELIVER A HIGH,
AS BRETT PESCE HAS
VINCENT TROCHECK HAS THE POWER
PLAY GOAL, TO SEPOINT OF THE NIT